U ist Unterhaltung von Florentin und Stefan, F steht für Verantwortung, O ist die Oma, die gar nicht existiert, aber es wird sich mehr aber auch nicht. U steht für kein Urlaub, ihr sendet immer durch, O steht für Onlyfans, O steht für Ohrenkamera und andere Gets ich bin bereit für Spaß, Spaß, komm auf mich zu! Ich habe nie verstanden, lass die Arme unten, was sollen die Arme oben, das ist ja der Merkspruch, was sollen die Arme oben, lass die Arme unten. Put your hands down for Detroit, ja, ihr würdet Detroit mehr helfen, wenn ihr die Arme runternehmt, Arme runter, wenn uns die deutsche Geschichte einst gelernt hat, dann Arme runter, je tiefer der Arm, desto besser geht es allen. Runter mit den Armen, dafür wurden Rosentaschen erfunden. Rosentaschen sind cool, steckt die da rein oder in den Rucksack oder in sonstige Taschen und Öffnungen. Ausser bei Vorträgen. Ausser bei Vorträgen, da und dann auf dem Tisch. Oder einfach in den Schritt vorne, also einfach so Dick Grab. Ja, einfach konsthalten. Das sind TJ und Jojo gewesen. Die TJ und Jojo? TJ und Jojo, zwei sehr ausgefallene Namen. Kein Wunder, dass die beiden den ganzen Tag sehr gut drauf sind. Nur weil du wieder einfach was assumest und aus TJ TJ machst. Ach so, du meinst, er heißt TJ? Da steht ja nicht TJ. Der heißt Theodor Johannes und er nennt sich TJ. Ja, genau. Ich bin Theodor Johannes, aber du kannst mich TJ nennen. TJ. Ja, da waren wir ja schon mal vor ein paar Folgen. TJ, also die deutschen Abkürzungen, dieses TJ oder dieses, weiss ich nicht, GGL oder Donald J. Trump. Alles hat so einen gewissen, so einen Flang, so einen Ring. Ja, das stimmt. Das haben wir im Deutschen nicht. Wir haben weder Ring noch Flair. Wir haben nichts, Ring noch Flair. Nee, wir haben nichts, wir haben einfach nur dann TJ. TJ, Judoku, aber dafür haben wir Junior und Senior. Das ist auch gut, das ist auch nicht schlecht. Das stimmt, das gefällt mir sehr. Wärst du lieber Senior oder Junior? Immer, ähm. Einer mehr als du. Immer drüber, Senior, Senior. Lieber natürlich Junior, weil es zwar die Expertise suggeriert, die in der Familie vorherrscht, aber dann lieber dann doch vielleicht ist man noch jung. Ich finde, wenn du, wenn du, sorry. Du greifst das übergriffig und scheiße, du hast aber meinen Kopfhörer jetzt leise gemacht. Ja, aber das ist unser Bein. Weißt du, wir haben uns doch gerade durch das Intro, haben wir uns doch wieder vertragen. Was denn da, wie kaputt deine Ohren sind, dass das deine normale Lautstärke ist. Das so ist, bin ich. Nee, du, hör auf, bei mir rumzudrehen, dann hast du das Problem einfach nicht. Ja, aber das ist ja dann der andere. Wenn jeder bei seinen fucking Knöpfen bleibt, dann haben wir ja. Podcaster, bleib bei deinen Knöpfen. Bleib bei deinen Knöpfen. Ja, alles klar, gut, dann haben wir es doch. Ja, haben wir es doch ja warum sind wir heute so verdammt gut drauf ich habe Quarkbärchen gegessen kurz für Aufnahme ich bin richtig gut drauf ich habe fünf Quarkbärchen gegessen weil ich mir einfach dachte warum eigentlich nicht ich bin zum Bäcker gegangen und dachte mir richtig ich dachte mir natürlich zwei Laugenbrezeln hole ich mir klar für den Tag für den weiteren Verlauf des Tages brauche ich ein bisschen Kraft, brauche ich ein bisschen Salz, damit die Maschine richtig tuckert. Wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie? Du läufst auf Salz? Ich laufe auf Salz. Ich bin jetzt komplett auf Salz umgestiegen. Habe ich gehört, der Florentin läuft auf Salz? Ja, du hast richtig gehört, der Florentin läuft auf Salz. Ich bin Stefan und ich laufe auf Zucker. Das ist wie so ein Kennenlernenspiel, so ein Icebreaker-Spiel. Ah ja, stimmt, finde ich aber gar nicht so schlecht. Jeder muss sich vorstellen, worauf er läuft. Also im Sinne von, was ist dein Antrieb? What are you running on? Ich bin die Jojo und ich laufe auf Bücher. Ich bin der TJ und ich laufe auf Musik. So, was treibt dich an? Genau, wie Benzin bei Autos, ich laufe mit ... Genau, ich laufe mit ... Ich dachte gerade eher sagen, ich dachte gerade nur, wie wir uns der Knie vor der englischen Sprache. Ja, ach du liebes Lottchen. Ach Gott, wir lachen auf den Knie in Griechen wir an und sagen, englische Sprache, gib uns neue Formulierungen. Dabei haben wir doch alles. Ja, aber die, ich laufe. Lass die Arme unten. Lass die Arme unten. Verdammt noch mal, lass die Arme unten.
Es ist auch ein Gesundheitsrisiko.
Es ist ein Gesundheitsrisiko für oben
und vor allem die Säbelst auch einfach die Hände ab.
Das passiert ja regelmäßig bei Achterbahnen,
dass die einfach dann ein neues Kabel
verlegen oder so und plötzlich hast du so eine
Fuhre, wo alle Hände
ab und dann kannst du mal gucken,
was da frittiert wird, schön am Snackstand.
So, da kriegst du dann die ganze...
Da wird dann nichts weggeschmissen. In so einem Vergnügungspark, der wird nicht weggeschmissen, da bleibt da nichts liegen. Alles, was die Besucher ausspeien und alles, was da runterfällt, wird alles mitgenommen. Die stehen noch unten mit ihrem Eimer, mit dem ganzen Kleingeld. So ein frittierter Hut! Ja, sicher, da kommt ja alles rein, das ist ja frittiertes Kleingeld. Helge Schneider, Witz sind wir jetzt. Das ist doch keiner Pommes, das ist doch ein Hut. Urang-Utan-Klaus, das ist doch kein Name für eine Katze. Die alten Sachen von Helge Schneider sind ab, jetzt sind wir einmal voll Zirkel gekommen. Helge Schneider, Seinfeld und wieder Helge Schneider zurück. Einmal komplett rum. Aber ich glaube, es ist wirklich so, im Vergnügungspark, da bleibt nichts liegen. Da hast du ja unter der Achterbahn die Leute, die da stehen und das Kleingeld auffangen. Oder die dritten Zähne, die da rausfallen. Oder irgendwie das Portemonnaie, das da rausfällt. Und dann hast du da den Goofy, der irgendwie da in seiner Mittagspause dann noch da reingepeitscht wird, um dann irgendwie noch so Ommers alten G-Stock aufzufangen, der dann da einfach verscherbelt wird. Da musst du richtig aufpassen. Du musst höllisch aufpassen. So wurden ja ursprünglich Achterbahnen erfunden. Die Leute wurden geschüttelt, um denen die losen, weil früher gab es keine Geldbeutel, du hattest ja dein Geld immer in der Hand. In der Hand oder in der Tasche oder du hattest halt einen Diener, der es dir halt mit so offener Hand hinhängt, wie so ein Aschenbecher. Und unter dir herläuft, Sir, Sir, Sir, Sir, Sir, ja, ich weiss! Wir haben, Sir, Sir, Sir, Sir, Sir, Sir, Sir, ja, ich hab's verstanden! Sie haben zu wenig Geld mitgenommen. Ja, du musst mir nicht alles immer konstant sagen, weil ich weiss, wir kennen uns noch nicht lange, oh du, da brich mich doch nicht! Sieben Mark fünfzig, sieben Mark fünfzig. Wann wird endlich ein Lederbeutel erfunden, der dich ersetzt? Es tut mir leid, ich muss so grob sein! Niemand kann mich ersetzen, ich zähle, ich sag ihm, was ich haben. Doch, du kannst einfach ersetzt werden. Entweder durch eine Plastikkarte oder einen Lederbeutel, der dich... Nein, nein. Ich bin nicht umsonst Zacharias Montgomery Junior. Gut, ja, alles klar. Sie wurden mir empfohlen als bester Diener der Welt, aber einfach leise, leise. Ich laufe ab im siebten April 2028. Nur, dass Sie Bescheid wissen. Das kommt vor. Meine Glückszahl ist die, das finde ich auch schade, dass es nicht Glückszahl heisst auf der Karte, der Sicherheitscode, der dreistellige Code. Du meinst, jeder sollte auf seiner Kreditkarte noch eine Glückszahl haben, einfach am Ende. Dass man die einfach staatlich verschrieben bekommt, finde ich aber eine gute Idee. Einfach nur aus Spaß. Einfach so mal ganz so nebenbei. Es gibt mir ja auch viel verloren in diesem knallharten kapitalistischen Alltag, in dem wir leben. Ein bisschen Spaß. Macht eine Zahl drauf auf die Karte, die ihr gar nicht braucht. Ist alles verloren gegangen. Auf jeden Fall. Gebt einfach mal so einen Tennisball raus, auch bei den Behörden oder so. Ich wurde geblitzt, ich wurde knallhart geblitzt, die Schweine haben mich erwischt und ja, ich sehe richtig dumm aus auf dem Bild auch und ich war... Aber wenigstens gibt es ein Bild. Manchmal hat man nicht immer das lustige Bild. Und dann denke ich mir, wofürofür wurde eigentlich geblitzt das ist aber tatsächlich das einzige was worauf ich mich freue wenn ich geblitzt werde denke ich einerseits okay blöd andererseits ich freue mich aufs bild weil ich habe ich versuche mich zu erinnern dass ich gerade richtig dumm aussah eigentlich gerade und ich sah auch richtig dumm aus wie der dumm ist so wie schnell darf man hier fahren wir sind auch oben geg offenem Mund? Also es gäbe eine Brille, über die du drüber gucken müsstest, die es aber nicht gibt. Ja, es ist ein verzweifelter Versuch über die Nase. Mund halb offen? Mund halb offen, mit so einer wie schnell darf ich hier, zack, Blitz erwischt. Geblendet auch leicht, Lenkrad verrissen. Leicht schon geblendet. Ja, und das gefährlich ist ja, also wenn normalerweise, wenn ich so einen Blitzerbrief kriege, dann nehme ich mir, was muss ich zahlen, mach mal den Tresor auf, wie viel wollen sie denn jetzt, na dann nimm doch, bitte, bitte, bitte, dann greife ich einmal in meine Dienerhand rein und eine Handvoll Gülden wird dann halt auch in Richtung des Kassiers geworfen. Aber diesmal war es ein Brief ohne Strafe, ohne Kosten. Und das sind ja die richtig harten, wo man dann noch um Anhörungsbogen geht, weil ich bin ordentlich zu schnell gefahren. Es war eine wirklich linke Situation, muss man sagen. Es war irgendwie ich wurde gelinkt. Und ja, deswegen jetzt kann es gut sein, dass ich bald hintergittern muss, weil ich jetzt tatsächlich zu schnell gefahren bin in der Situation, da ist reduziert und ich bin aber die allige Geschwindigkeit gefahren, alles so einfach eine Falle, einfach eine komplette Falle für mich. Hört ihr das da draussen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer? Man kann auch ohne Hash-Browns und Joints und gestresst und Giieskern im Auto geblitzt werden.
Und dieses, wenn du jetzt noch das Podcast-Ofer gehört hättest, hätten wir, Gott sei Dank,
vielleicht auch, das würde ich sehr an dir zweifeln, wenn wir es anfangs, deinen eigenen
Podcast zu hören, aber so wäre dann natürlich klar, dass man dir das bezahlt.
So haben wir immer noch unsere Rubrik.
Wir haben uns zwar entschieden, ich muss kurz nachfragen, wir haben uns entschieden, dass wir unserem Hörer das bezahlen. Genau. Es gibt aber, ich habe noch keinen Überweisungsträger bekommen. Ja, ja, ja, ja, die Zahlen müssen noch ausgewürfelt und berechnet werden. Aber schicke ich dir, in der Zwischenzeit können wir über den Fall von Mike entscheiden, denn Mike schreibt uns. Moment, aber genau daran schließe ich meine Frage an. Die Aktion ist ja vorbei. Jetzt fängst du wieder an, etwas vorzulesen. Sie ist offiziell vorbei, aber es ist natürlich, der Backcatalog muss noch abgearbeitet werden von den ganzen Sachen, die reingekommen sind. Du kannst ja nicht einfach sagen, es ist vorbei. Wie viele willst du davon bezahlen? Lass uns mit Mike einfach jetzt beenden. Okay, super. Mike, du hast jetzt die Verantwortung, der Letzte zu sein. Mike schreibt, es hat rot geblitzt, mein Portemonnaie wurde leichter und ihr seid Beifahrer gewesen. Kurz Rückblende. Oh, ich liebe alles an der Mail. Yes, yes, yes, yes, alles perfekt. Wie ist der Betreff der Mail? Der Betreff lautet völkerschlacht geblitzt dieser mann hat das internet verstanden er hat uns verstanden er hat mails verstanden du musst knallhart rein dann ist es fast wie so ein was was bist du eigentlich zwei wochen vorher ich will so ein cold opening ja du musst die erstez ist zwei Wochen vorher. So denkst du, wow, ich bin schon zeitlich verwirrt.
Ihr schreibt Mails so, sehr geehrte Dear Sir and Madam at Harvard und dann schreibt ihr eure Bewerbung und dann wundert ihr euch, warum ihr keine fucking Absage bekommt, weil ihr nicht einsteigt wie Mike. Ja, absolut. Kurze Rückblende. Am 26.07. war es soweit. Nach langem Reden hatte ich meine Freundin endlich soweit.
Ich konnte unter dem Vorbehalt eines Städtetrips mit Shopping, gutem Essen und vielem mehr endlich Leipzig ansteuern. Doch sind wir ehrlich, wir wollten dort nur eins. Ficken. Fast. Die Völkerschlacht von 1813 hautnah erleben. Es ist nur eine Sache besser als Sex. Die Völkerschlacht von 1813 hautnah erleben, Napoleon wurde hier geschlagen, das Rat der Zeit hielt für eine Weile still. Eigentlich drehte es sich da noch voran. Und so machte ich mich die Tage davor schlau, nichts ist besser als geschichtliche Fakten im Voraus lernen. Erstens, eine halbe Million Soldaten waren beteiligt. Zweitens, die Armee des russischen Zaren kämpfte noch mit Pfeile und Bogen. Drittens, andererseits wurden bereits Raketen eingesetzt. Ihr Erfinder, der britische Oberst William Congrave, hatte Raketen als Kriegswarfer erstmals in Indien kennengelernt und dann selber welche entwickelt. Sie wurden von transportablen Leitergestellen aus abgeschossen. Also, Pfeil und Bogen auf der einen Seite, Raketen auf der anderen Seite. Aber all der Fakten taumel wurde meiner Freundin zu viel. Sie wollte es auf der Fahrt nicht mehr hören. So habe ich die Stille der Fahrt genutzt und euch ins Auto gesetzt. Wir lauschten euren Stimmen, fuhren in Leipzig ab und Blitz! Da war es geschehen. 30 Euro und nun, naja, schade. Aber der Tag war super, ich habe eine 200 Jahre alte Rakete gesehen. Gesehen. Angefasst dachte ich jetzt, nee, gesehen. So, also jetzt ist das der Fall von Mike. Völkerschlacht, natürlich, die Verantwortungen sind historisch noch nicht ganz geklärt. Das wird natürlich jetzt historisch aufgearbeitet werden müssen, ob wir da jetzt auch teilschuldig sind. Jetzt ist man natürlich auch berauscht. Also jeder von uns kann alltäglich irgendwie 200 Jahre alte Raketen sehen. Da ist man natürlich berauscht, man ist berieselt, man hat Lust. man drückt vielleicht mal aufs Gaspedal, wenn man denkt, oh, ich will mir noch eine Doku reinziehen zur Schlacht von 1813. Man fühlt sich vielleicht selbst auch ein wenig wie eine Rakete, du bist im Geschwindigkeitstaube, du hast natürlich diese Raketen gesehen und dachtest dir wahrscheinlich, warum haben die die nicht abgefeuert? Oder umgedreht, du bist mit Langsamkeit und langsamen Gefährten konfrontiert und irgendwie Pferde, die noch irgendwelche Sachen ziehen mussten. Und dann setzt du dich ins Auto und ganz berieselt von diesem neuen Fortschritt willst du das dann auch auslusten und auf Gas drücken. Gut, dass heute nicht 1813 ist und drückst nochmal richtig auf die Tour. In beide Richtungen kann ich verstehen, dass du zu schnell gefahren bist. Und in beiden Sachen hat das Podcast-Ufo eine geringe bis fadenscheinlich gar keine Rolle. Richtig, tatsächlich auch nochmal hier hervorzuheben die Freundin, die anscheinend nach dem Besuch der Völkerschlacht auf der Heimfahrt nichts mehr davon hören wissen. Ich finde es gut. Ich dachte, das wäre die Hinfahrt gewesen. Also er beschreibt. Wir fuhren in Leipzig ab und blitz.
Das heißt, ich finde ganz gut, dass diese Freundin ihren Geschichtshunger genau gestillt hat. Genau in dem Moment, in dem sie sich ins Auto gesetzt hat, um nach Hause zu fahren, hat sie gesagt, ich bin satt, ich möchte nichts mehr hören, Napoleon, Raketen, Granaten ist jetzt aus. Dann eine Frage an dich, wenn du auf einem Konzert warst, zum Beispiel diese Band aus Dublin, du kommst von einem Konzert, hörst du dann die Band? Auf der Heimfahrt höre ich da das Album nochmal. Auf gar keinen Fall. Eben. Ich glaube, das ist normal. Ich glaube, es ist eher krankhaft von Mike, dass er nach dieser Veranstaltung dann noch weiter rein will. Man nennt sich,, es reicht. Ja, es reicht. 18 und 13 ist jetzt auch schon ein bisschen her. Jetzt muss das nächste Thema kommen. Nicht nur in der Vergangenheit, guck mal nach vorn. Er hat dann das Podcast UFO angemacht und ich sehe tatsächlich da eher den Fakten-Taumel und natürlich auch die Wut über den Ausgang der Schlacht. Er hat jetzt gar nicht parteibezogen, was mich wundert, weil das ja natürlich, da kommt man nicht umhin, historische Ereignisse, da neigt man oft dazu zu sagen, man ist dann doch auf einer Seite, so, dann ist ja, das ist ja wie so eine Beziehung, die in die Brüche geht. Je mehr du drüber lernst, desto mehr hast du instinktiv eine Seite und kannst das eigentlich gar nicht verhindern. Also ich glaube niemand. Je mehr du weißt, desto weniger willst du eine Seite einbeziehen. Danny Krüger, Danny Klose? Danny Krüger,. Ach, dann den Krüger, okay. Je mehr du über etwas weisst, desto mehr siehst du einen, dass du eigentlich gar nichts weisst. Dann würde man ja eher gar keine Parteien greifen. Das heißt Danny-Krüger-Effekt. Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass es Danny-Krüger-Effekt heißt. Vielleicht sind wir da wieder dem Nelson Mandela-Effekt aufgesessen, und du hast wahrscheinlich völlig recht. Dazu ein kurzer Einschub, Mini-Einschub. Pikachu, ohne jetzt zu googeln, da draußen. Ah, der Schwanz. Der Schwanz. Ne, er hat keinen schwarzen Schwanz. Ja, aber in meinem Kopf hat er einen schwarzen Schwanz. Und alle Bilder sehen schwachsinnig aus. Ja. Der hat einen schwarzen Schwanz. Also das Ende Ja, wir sind alle da, wir sind alle noch da. Niemand ist gegangen, niemand hat die Hände in die Höhe. Wir letzte Reihe kichert immer, das ist doch jetzt egal. In der letzten Reihe kichern sie wegen schwarzer Schwanz. Ja, nein, Pikachu hat explizit keinen schwarzen, und es geht nur auf die Nerven, und es wird immer der Unterricht gestört, weil da hinten gekichert wird. Also, zum Thema Mike, 30 Euro übernimmt das die Podcast-UFO-Kasse, Ich würde sagen, nein! Abgelehnt! Ich würde sagen, ja. Gut. Dann kämpfen wir bis auf den Ton. 15 Euro. Die Hälfte. Ich greife in meiner Tasche. Okay. Stefan zahlt? Dina. Dina. Jawohl, mein Herr. 15, 15, 20. Ja! Oh Gott. Wie viele Geräusche müssen die nicht sein. Können wir nicht einfach Liederbeutel haben? Können wir einfach Lederbeutel haben? Ja, weil, ja, können wir nicht einfach Lederbeutel haben, einfach was das ersetzt. Nee, ich finde, das sollten wir bezahlen. Ich sage, wir sollen es nicht bezahlen. Warum? Nein, wir möchten uns an diesen, weil natürlich, ich habe einfach Angst, dass Mike sich von den 15 Euro eine Rakete kauft. Ich glaube, der macht da nicht Stopp. Der sagt den Geschwindigkeitstaumel. Auf die Gedachte nur sagen wir, für wen wir in der Schlacht sind. Drei, zwei, eins, der Zar. Russland. Ja, guck mal, da sind wir doch. Bei Pfeil und Bogen, natürlich die Underdogs auf jeden Fall, da sind wir doch dabei. Hat ja auch was so von Elbisches irgendwie, dass die Pfeil und Bogen und dann so Samurai-mäßig Last Samurai, aber da spoilert der Titel ja auch schon ein bisschen, wie es ausgeht.
Cool, haben wir das noch geklärt? Gut, Mike beerdigt nicht nur Napoleons Kriegstreiben, sondern auch diese Rubrik, das war's, mit der Rubrik Blitzgewitter, in der wir uns Verantwortung aufbürden, was wir nicht tun möchten. Wir würden aber gerne weiterhin Verantwortung übernehmen. Also egal, was sonst so in eurem Leben passiert. Man fragt, wer geht's billiger? Ja, das ist unser Anliegen. Geht's billiger? Also angenommen, eine Beziehung geht in die Brüche wegen des Podcast-Rufos. Wir rufen nochmal an, wir versuchen zu klären, wir versuchen zu vermitteln. Angenommen eine Familienfete geht den Bach runter, nimmt ein unerwartetes Ende wegen dem Podcast-UFO, wie auch immer das aussieht. Ah okay, wir müssen schon Schuld haben. Wir müssen natürlich schon, ja klar, sonst können wir auch keine Verantwortung übernehmen. Also falls Dinge in eurem Leben passieren. Ich bin inzwischen dafür, auch Verantwortung für Dinge zu übernehmen, wo man gar nicht unbedingt die Verantwortung übernehmen muss. Du willst einfach mehr Verantwortung auf dem Teller. Du kriegst den Teller nicht. Das ist ein großes Thema bei mir. Es ist sowas im Gegenteil. Dass du keine Verantwortung übernehmen willst? Demand avoidance. Du willst keine Ansprüche annehmen, die an dich gestellt werden. Genau. Ich möchte mich lösen von Ansprüchen und mich keine Verantwortung übernehmen müssen. Ich bin eher auf der, wenn es ein großes Spektrum ist, auf der recht extremen Ausprägung Demand-Avoidance. Also auf so eine Acht, wenn so eine Skala ist. Wie prägt sich das konkret aus? Kannst du da ein Beispiel geben? Oder ist das jetzt schon zu viel Demand? Also wenn ich jetzt sage,
macht.
Ich fühle mich ein bisschen eingeengt und denke mir so,
jetzt muss ich ja,
also weil du so eine klare Frage gestellt hast, die jetzt an mich
gerichtet ist.
Ich fühle mich jetzt
also mega unwohl. Okay, okay, das tut mir leid,
alles klar.
Das ist einfach jetzt scheiße gelaufen. Ja, ja, ja. Ein bisschen erinnere ich mich an unsere, an eine unserer letzten Folgen, wo wir über den Bach-Bäcker-Fachverkäufer gesprochen haben. Zwei Weltmeisterbrötchen? Der Zwei Weltmeisterbrötchen schon mal bereitlegt, da fühle ich dann schon eine Art Verantwortung für seine
gute Laune.
Und fühle mich fast übergriffig, wenn ich den ablehne.
Und das fühle ich mich schon als Eingriff.
Also da bin ich schon, ich bin
zu sehr Teil seines Lebens geworden, das wäre mir
schon so. Ja, kann ich gut verstehen. Du könntest
ihn jetzt enttäuschen, dadurch, dass du eine Beziehung
besteht und dann hast du das Schuld.
Da schreibt übrigens
Jasi, die schreibt, ich habe lange in Wien in einer Teuren Bäckerei die Reichen und Schönen der Stadt bedient. Da war es allerdings so, dass dieses Klientel so dermassen drauf stand, dass wir wissen, was sie wollen und es ihnen schon zurücklegen, wenn wir sie ganz hinten in der Schlange sehen, am besten noch mit Namen ansprechen und den Kaffee schon fertig zubereitet haben, wenn sie vorne an der Theke stehen. Also ja, sie beschreibt hier natürlich, dass Wiener Klientel, also das ist natürlich so ein bisschen die Höhergestellte, die Ebenen an Wien, da will man es nicht so natürlich auch gut gehen lassen, ist klar.
Ja, ich kann es mir vorstellen, wir hatten ja auch schon darüber gesprochen, also gerade so Senioren haben wir beispielhaft genannt, die vielleicht nicht so viel sozialen Kontakt haben und dann natürlich in der Bäckerei gehen, da werden sie erkannt, da haben sie die, da reden sie mal fünf Sätze, das ist toll. Ja. Und dann fühlen sie sich gesehen und gehört und fühlen sich nicht fehl am Platz. Ein anderes Beispiel wäre ein Kumpel, der ist sehr so wie wir eingestellt, der war aber in New York mal ein Jahr oder ein halbes zum Arbeiten. Und da hat er sich morgens immer einen Kaffee geholt. Und in dieser grossen, anonymen Stadt, wo man eh nicht zu Hause ist, sondern kurz mal da ist, fand er es irgendwann schön und stand da irgendwann Kaffee. Und da war meine erste Reaktion nicht abstoßend, oh, oh, oh, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, wie es bei dir geht. Gitter weg, weg, weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, gitter weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg, geht er weg,chreitung, weil man natürlich oft auch nochmal sagt, komm jetzt nochmal den Muffin obendrauf.
Und ich glaube, das Schlimmste für mich wäre, wenn ich in die Bäckerei gehe und sage, ah, wieder die fünf Quarkbällchen, du so, das wäre glaube ich das Schlimmste für mich.
Wie wärst du mal mit zehn? Wie viel kannst du fressen? Wie viel kannst du den in deinen Mund stecken? Pass auf, du zahlst, pass auf, wir machen die.
Da ist sogar ein bisschen Platz. Komm mal kurz alle her. Er ist wieder da. Ja, ja, ja, Quarkbildchen geil, ja, ja, Quark. Boah, ey, oh, ey, der ist ja noch mehr, boah. Also hier, du musst nicht zahlen, Deal, okay, du musst nicht zahlen, dafür zeigst du uns, wie viele Quarkbildchen du auf einmal in den Mund nehmen kannst, okay? Hier, Kamps zahlt. Hier, komm, ich steck dir,, mach mal den Mund, komm mal näher, komm mal näher, komm mal näher, mach den Mund auf. Das ist nicht ein bisschen übergriffig für eine Bäckerei. Mach den Mund auf. Ja. Weiter, weiter, hol mal so eine Laugenstange, die können wir nicht mehr so reinstecken, wenn wir den Mund aufblachen. Ja, ja, ja, okay, hier. So, jetzt hier hast du den ersten Quarkbärchen. Schmeckt's? Ja. Sag, wie es schmeckt. Ja, ich schmeck gut. Sag, dass du mehr willst. Bettel drum. Bettel um Zucker und Fett. Ich will noch mehr, bitte, gib mir bitte mehr, ich kann noch viel mehr essen.
Und ich stehe so daneben und will einfach nur gleich zwei Weltmeister-Räte bestellen. Aber das wäre tatsächlich auch eine Horrorvorstellung für mich.
Also wenn das passieren würde, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Ich meine, in Wien mag man das.
Ja, in Wien ist das immer gern gesehen, aber hier eben noch nicht. Aber da würde, fändes Bild, wenn mir gespiegelt wird, ach du isst jedes Mal fünf Quarkbällchen. Deswegen Quarkbällchen sind für mich natürlich immer gern gesehen, aber es soll eine Ausnahme bleiben. Intern weiß ich natürlich, es ist keine Ausnahme, ich hole mir jedes Mal die fünf Quarkbällchen, weil ich mag, was ich an Quarkbärchen mag, ist die Konsistenz. Und damit meine ich nicht die Beschaffenheit, sondern dass sie immer gleich sind. Konsistenz, Konsistenz, die Konsistenz. Und zwar, ich habe das Gefühl, von allen Nahrungsmitteln gibt es ein großes Spektrum von sind immer exakt gleich und sind immer komplett unterschiedlich.
Auf der komplett unterschiedlichen Seite die komplette indische Küche, das Gefühl schmeckt jedes mal anders, jedes einzelne Gericht. Und auch das Problem, dass die Läden alle ähnlich heissen. Also es gibt Mumbai Palace, Gate to Mumbai, Gate to India und dann India Palace. Dann gibt es so welche, die sind komplett out there mit so einem anderen Namen.
Daily Panace, ja.
Ja, ja, aber das ist immer das Problem, dass die immer, und ich weiss immer, also, weil ich bestelle jetzt nicht so häufig indisch, dass ich irgendwie ein Stammlokal habe. Dadurch bestelle ich immer woanders und ich bin immer extrem glücklich oder extrem enttäuscht. Ja, ja. Weil ich mache keinen Fortschritt in der Bestellung, das ist so, da kann man mal in Ruhe, machen wir mal eine spezielle Folge.
Ich habe jetzt tatsächlich einen indischen Lieferservice aufgegeben, weil da habe ich gerne bestellt, weil ich fand, die hatten ein gutes Naan. Und irgendwann habe ich gemerkt, das Naan wurde immer dünner. Und irgendwann habe ich tatsächlich angefangen, es zu wiegen. Also ich habe wirklich angefangen, es zu wiegen. Ich finde, wenn man der schrecklichste Kunde der Welt ist, hat man inzwischen auch sein Recht verwirkt, der beste Kunde, generell über Kunde, Kaufmann, Kauffrau Beziehung entscheiden zu können. Das stimmt schon, aber ich dachte, ich wollte eben eine objektive Meinung haben, ich wollte nicht subjektiv da rangehen, weil ich dachte, kann ja auch sein, dass ich immer fetter werde und mein Hunger immer steigt. Und deswegen nehme ich die klein wahr, wenn ich so riesig gross werde, wirkt alles klein. Deswegen habe ich sie gewogen und es wurde tatsächlich, es ging langsam runter von 190 auf 160 Gramm. Und dann habe ich in einem verzweifelten Versuch immer noch als Beschreibung dazu geschrieben, bitte Dick, bitte Dick, ohne zu wissen, ob das überhaupt jemand liest.
Und dann kam er zu dir an der Tür. Bitte Dick, komm mal hier, komm Leute, komm Leute, bring's, bring's.
Dann haben wir so einen riesen Nahen, dann haben sie die gebacken. Mach den Mund auf, mach den Mund auf, mach den Mund auf.
Und der Becker ist auch dabei, die ganzen Becker-Jungs sind auch dabei.
Nee, das fände ich echt blöd, wenn das passieren würde.
Bitte Dick, bitte Dick.
Bitte Dick. Und ich weiß auch nicht, wer das liest, ob dasest, ob das in der App wirklich jemand schon bei der Bestellung sagt, bitte Dick, aber es wurde nicht dicker. Vor allem die Vorstellung, dass sie wahrscheinlich besser Englisch sprechen als Deutsch und dann bitte Dick, Dick please, ist halt fucking weird. Aber ich glaube eh, dass die nicht jedes Naan extra backen für jede Bestellung, sondern die werden da am Anfang des Tages was haben. Deswegen ist das alles umsonst. Aber ich habe zumindest versucht, ihnen noch die Chance zu geben und habe jetzt diese Geschäftsbeziehung beendet. Aber spannend, dass wir ein ähnlicher, wir sind beide halt wahnsinnige Pedanten, muss man auch mal sagen, weil ich war neulich, wollte ich indisch bestellen, wusste nicht mehr, wo es gut mal war. Und dann muss ich mir wieder ganzen Läden neu erschliessen. Dann nimmt man die, die irgendwie einigermaßen gut bewertet ist und vergleicht. Und was ich dann schon nicht mag, ist, dass das Butter Chicken in verschiedenen Schärfegraden daherkommt. Und zwar in vier verschiedenen Schärfegraden. Da denke ich mir, nee, ich will so ein, ich will so ein Gatekeeptes, es ist wie es immer ist, es ist schon das Rezept von meiner Urgrossoma und da so wird Butter Chicken gemacht hier bei uns. Und entweder du kommst damit klar oder nicht und dann ist da die Tür, das ist Gate out of India, tschüss. Vier ist viel zu viel, es sollte niemals mehr als drei Auswahlmöglichkeiten geben, egal bei was, es gibt Gross, Mittel, Klein, Genau. Es braucht nicht mehr vier. Vier ist eine Kackzahl.
Ich glaube, ist das nicht so dieser psychologische Effekt, dass bei vier es keine Mitte gibt und man dann eher tendiert zu, also wenn du sagst, drei, klein, mittel, gross, nimmt man Mittel, weil du hast keine Ahnung was. Wohingegen, wenn es sehr klein, klein, mittel, gross nimmt, nimmst du wahrscheinlich das dritte und dann verkauft man mehr insgesamt aber ich hasse das zum beispiel auch war ich
letztens hier bei einer fleischtheke und habe gesagt zwei paar wiener würstchen und da kam die
frage ja das kann doch nicht wahr sein es ist mir heute schon zweimal Zwei mal. Hä, ist der da? Will ihr, will ich wieder Würstchen haben? Ja, ich will wieder Würstchen haben. Please dick. Ja, ich will das dicke Würstchen haben. Machen wir den mit auf. Ja. Und ja, aber. Florentin. Ja, aber so. Irgendwo muss ich ja essen. Ich muss ja auch was essen. Du musst auch was essen. Und dann sage ich bitte zwei Paarer Würstchen und dann ja klein, mittel oder gross. Und ich denke mir, ich will ein Wiener Würstchen, die haben doch eine Grösse. Manche Dinge haben Grösse. Es gibt gewisse Nahrungsmittel, die haben eine gewisse Grösse und da gibt es kein klein oder gross. Wenn ich sage, ich hätte gerne extra grosse Wiener Würstchen, okay. Aber ich finde, das ist keine zulässige Frage. Es gibt gewisse Dinge, die haben eine Grösse. Wenn du sagst, ich hätte gerne Schokokuss und dann fragt, klein oder gross. Das gibt es nicht. Mich ärgert es ja schon, wenn bei Brezel gesagt wird, gross oder klein. Dann hätte ich gesagt, wenn ich eine grosse, wenn ich so eine Wiesenbrezel haben wolle, dann hätte ich sie auch gesagt. Aber eine Brezel hat einfach eine Standardgrösse. Also du kannst ja kleine und große anbieten, aber wenn jemand sagt Brezel, dann erstmal normal. So, nervt mich. Und dann hab ich, vor allem, dann hab ich bei dem Wiener Würstchen, du kennst mich ja, ich werd dann ja ganz klein und, oh, ich weiss es nicht, ich weiss, tut mir leid, dass ich oft da bin. Und dann hat er gesagt, ja, klein, gross oder mittler. Naja, halt normal, halt normal, ganz normal, ich weiß es nicht. Schnell mal lauter, ich verstehe dich hier gar nicht. Und dann habe ich gesagt, bitte normal und er so, ah, also die grossen. Und da dachte ich mir, alles ist, diese Welt ist verloren. Also diese Welt einfach wirklich nicht mal ohne Zwischenspeicherung. Erst der Bäcker, dann die Frischhalte-Stücke. Weil wenn du sagst, klein, mittel oder gross und ich sag normal und er sagt also die grossen, dann brennt dieses, dann nehmt das Fleisch und brennt es nieder und nehmt das Gebäude und stampft es ein, drückt es einfach so wie es ist komplett in den Boden und planiert drüber und baut einen neuen Supermarkt drauf und fangt nochmal bei null an. Das ist meine Idee dafür, weil da geht da hinten, da hilft nichts mehr. Das ist verloren. Das ist vorüber.
Ich habe neulich ein Video gesehen, wo ein Junge, der war vielleicht ein bisschen jünger als wir, aber so auf jeden Fall zu alt für das, was er jetzt vorhat, nämlich er ist zu dieser Fleischtheke gegangen und hat nochmal die Mortadella, die man als Kind bekommt, die Kindermortadella danach gefragt. Und dann kam die Frage, wie alt bist du denn? Ja, 27, ja komm hier. Und natürlich für alle ein grosser Jux, alle lachen, alle haben eine gute Zeit.
Und das ist vielleicht so für mich als versöhnende Anekdote, würde ich dir das gerne reichen. Warum hört das denn irgendwann eigentlich auf, dass man Sachen geschenkt bekommt, dass man einfach noch mal was irgendwie dabei gibt? Bist du so ein Probierer? Ich war letztens in so einem italienischen Supermarkt und da stand so extra so ein Tisch mit kleinen Brotwürfeln und dann wirklich so zehn Teller mit Olivenöl.
Und da war wirklich die Idee, ich soll jetzt zehn, also Brot mit zehn Olivenöl essen, also ist das nicht alleine schon eine komplette Mahlzeit, Olivenöl?
Und dann ist wirklich, wirklich von mir erwartet, ich soll bei zehn Olivenölen überhaupt mal einen Unterschied schmecken, was für mich eine Herausforderung ist, weil ich normalerweise Jahrmarktschaumbuffeln esse. Und dann, ich war so gestresst, ich hätte wirklich schon Angstschweiß auf der Stirn, weil ich mir dachte, nie im Leben. Ich brauche einen Block, ich brauche eine Tabelle, ich brauche Kriterien. Und vor allem, ich kann ja jetzt auch nicht das Erste probieren, das Zweite probieren und dann sagen, ich nehme das Zweite und das nehme ich. Ja, das ist das sekretärinnen dilemma okay also der begriff ist natürlich super old school und doof aber nennen wir es sekretärinnen dilemma der die idee ist wenn hundert menschen sich bewerben Auf den Job. Bei wie viele muss man sehen, mindestens, um einigermaßen einschätzen zu können, ob jemand deutlich besser als der Durchschnitt ist oder deutlich schlechter als der Durchschnitt ist. Und die Antwort ist 28. Also bei den ersten 28 kannst du erst mal sagen, nein danke. Ach so, die haben ... Und dann nimmst du den nächst besseren. Dasisst auf die Olivenöl übertragen ungefähr nach drei Olivenölen weiss ich ungefähr was so das Spektrum ist. Nach 28 von 100 meintest du ja oder? Also bei 10 sind es drei ja weiss ich es gibt ja mehr als 10 Olivenölen nach 28 sagst du ja oder nein kannst du danach ja, das ist ein gutes Olivenöl oder nicht? Ich habe glaube, ich bin bis vier gekommen und dann bin ich gegangen, weil es mir zu doof war. Dann hast du dich übergeben und dann kamen die Quarkbällchen und dann kamen. Ja, weil ich habe, ja, ja, ja, ich habe gemerkt, dass ich so in meinem Kopf in meinem Kopf drin bin mit, ich muss es dann auch irgendwie kommentieren und so für mich so, aha, aha, aha, aha, aha, aha, und merke, ich schmecke nichts, ich fühle nichts, ich habe nichts, ich bin nur in meiner Performance drin, habe ich aufgegeben. Aber ja, ich bin da immer gerne. Ja, ich finde es eine tolle Idee. Genau, und dann wollte ich indisch bestellen und dann ist für mich das grosse Problem, weil ich will Garlic Naan. Ich liebe Knoblauch, ich liebe es. Ich weiss. Und deswegen wollte ich gerne Garlik-Nan. Das Problem ist aber, man kann... Vielleicht halt nicht, wenn du Gesellschaft hast, ne? Also es ist halt, ich glaube, das kann man immer gerne essen, wenn man alleine ist. Aber wenn halt, wenn wir alle, wenn wir drei... Wenn alle essen, wenn sind wir drei... Extra normales Nan bestellen und du sagst Garlik-Nan und wir explizit nochmal nachfragen. Ach, du willst wirklich als einziger das Galik-Naan? Und du sagst, ja, ich liebe Galik-Naan und dir dabei das Beuchlin reibst und schon mal mit so einem Zahnstocher den Mund reinigst. Wie soll ich euren Code immer lesen? Es ist ein Hinweis, es ist ein Hinweis. Ich kann euren Code nicht lesen, ich spreche den Code zu mir. Sagt doch einfach, wir wollen nicht. Du stinkst wie ein Schwein! So, danke für die Ehrlichkeit. Damit kann ich was anfangen. Aber auf Garlicknahn ist ja auch Butter drauf, ne? Also das ist Butter und Knoblauch. Butter, an Butter kommt man nicht zu kurz, wenn man indisch bestellt. Ja. Ich möchte dann aber kein Reis, ich mag Reis nicht, bin kein Reisfanan. Und dann kann man manchmal bei indischen Restaurants kann man nicht Butter Chicken mit Gnan bestellen. Das ist kein Reisfan. Ich mag Reis nicht. Das ist wirklich eine Beleidigung. Wieso? Reis ist nichts. Reis ist doch nicht nichts. Reis ist nicht nichts. Reis ist alles. Weißt du, was der Beweis ist, dass Reis nichts ist? Es wird immer mit was gegessen. Spargel ist auch nichts.
Gebratener Reis? Fried Reis? Immer was dran. Ich habe ja aktuelle Handprobleme und habe gegoogelt, wie kriegt man stärkere Hände, wie kann man Hände trainieren. Und eine Antwort war, man muss seine Hand in einen Sack Reis stecken und dann so auf und zu machen, weil du gegen den Widerstand des Reis. Und ich dachte mir, ich liebe es. Das hat so eine richtige Kung-Fu, asiatische Krieger-Ninja-Art. Ja, auch weil es diese Basic-Mittel sind. Genau. Ich liebe das. Und es ist perfekt in der Vorstellung, es hat wirklich Widerstand. Und ich bin mir jetzt nicht hundertprozentig sicher, aber wenn du tiefer gehst, hast du mehr Widerstand. Weiss ich nicht. So, war gar nicht gewichtig, gar nicht gewichtig, gar nicht gewichtig. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, das mache ich jetzt auch. Hat aber keinen Sack Reis, sondern hatte halt nur diese Fertig-Plastiktüten, ein Portion in Plastiktüte Reis und stand vor der Überlegung, soll ich jetzt wirklich zwanzig von denen aufschneiden? Und da dachte ich mir, nee, das ist gerade so falsch. Also ich bin so weit weg von diesem fernöstlichen Reis-Ninja-Samurai-Warrior, weil ich mit diesen fertigen fünf Minuten Doktor-Benz-Dingern da und dachte mir, nee, lass ich's, bin ich weiter krank. Aber? Ui, jetzt wird ein Prop hervorgeholt. Ich hab jetzt Armschienen. Oh, here we go. Das ist so fucking uncool. Das ist das Gegenteil. Ich wollte gerade sagen, alles, was du beschrieben hast, ist wahnsinnig cool und awesome. Ja, das ist die deutsche Variante. Archaisches. Und ich dachte mir, die uncoole Variante wäre, du holst dir so einen bei Amazon, so einen fertigen Sandsack, wo dann so Gripmaster draufsteht. Oh ja, stimmt. Oder so Hand Strength. Und auch so Do Not Eat steht drauf. Genau, es ist richtig gross. Kein echter Reis, komischerweise. Genau, und da steht so richtig groß drauf, so Hand Strength von 3000. Ninja Death. Und dann machst du das, und das wäre so die westliche Alternative. Ich will ja, dass du wirklich so mit so Reissäcken rumläufst. Total gerne, total gerne. Mit so Bambus drumgeschnitten hast, und dann hast du noch so geile Striche im Gesicht. Und das ist natürlich das Uncoolste. Für mich gibt es mir so einen orthopädischen Sturm. So eine orthopädische Armschiene. Ich war beim Handarzt, ich habe erzählt davon, meine Hände taub und gefühlslos und gedönst, Verdacht auf Karpaltunnel-Syndrom. Ah, Karpal. Aber er kam jetzt zum Handarzt und dachte mir, saß da auch im Badezimmer und dachte mir, gibt man Ärzten eigentlich die Hand?
Ah ja, spannende Frage.
Gebe ich Arzt, gebe ich einem Handarzt die Hand oder kann ich bei dem mein Parkticket validieren?
Also all diese Fragen, weil ich bin nicht oft beim Arzt.
Und ich dachte wirklich, gibt man Ärzten die Hand? Eigentlich schon.
Das ist doch so dieses Ding, da gab es ja auch so Studien, wenn die einen kompetenten Handdruck haben, dann ist man automatisch zufrieden mit der Behandlung, weil die kompetent wirken und gedöhnt.
Und dann dachte ich mir, aber bei einem Handarzt ist es dann so der Gag, so ich gebe ihm mal nicht die Hand, oder laufe ich dann voll in den Gag rein? Ich war völlig ... Oh, Jesus, das Mikrofon habe ich aus meinem Gesicht gestellt.
Und dann habe ich auf jeden Fall ...
Kommst du her? Oh, Jesus, das Mikrofon habe ich aus dem Gesicht gestreift.
Und dann habe ich auf jeden Fall, kommst du her?
Das Mikrofon ist mir abhanden gekommen. Das ist in einem eigenen Podcast.
Das ist noch nie passiert, in 518 Folgen.
Nee, dass das Mikrofon einfach abhaut, das nicht.
Also seit der Covid-Covona-Pandemie sind wir alle aware und denken darüber nach über die Handsituation. Ja, ja, ist es wirklich noch so im Bewusstsein oder haben wir das bewunden? Post Covid, post Covid, let's not go there. Ich denke mir nur, ich war immer vorher schon bei Ärzten, mir die Situation bewusst, gebe ich dem gerade, dem Herrn oder der Dame die Hand oder nicht. Und da ist immer, ich lasse den Arzt kommen. Der Arzt entscheidet. So wie die Queen. Genau. So wie die Königin. Und wenn der Arzt mir einen Ring hinhält, so einen Siegelring, dann küsse ich den. Dann gehe ich auf die Knie und küsse ihn. Und er sagt, was machen Sie da? Küsse ihm so den Arm hoch. Ich dachte, das ist, was Sie wollen. Ja. Und er sagt, okay, auf weiter. Willst du noch einen Ring? Und dann habe ich tatsächlich es genauso gemacht. Ich habe auch überlegt, die Personen, aber es geht ja nicht. Ich glaube, man spiegelt sich ja immer so ein bisschen. Ein leichtes Zucken des einen wird schon vom anderen erwidert, so ein Handschlag ist ja zeitgleich. Es ist ja nicht so, dass der eine lange warten muss und so. Und am Ende habe ich dann wahrscheinlich aus der Nervosität heraus auch tatsächlich die Flosse hingehalten und es kam zu einem herzlichen Händedruck, wo ich mir auch schon dachte, da sagt sie gleich so, ja, so schlimm kann sie nicht sein. Na, was haben sie denn? So, und es war interessant, ich weiß nicht, was es ist, ich muss noch zum Neurologen, Nervenarzt, zum Thema
Karpaltunnelsyndrom, weil das
Puh, dieses sehr lustige Thema
ist sehr schnell, sehr ernst genommen. So, und jetzt hat die mir
aber die Armschienen verschrieben.
Die Neurologin schon?
Nein, die Handchirurgin, Ärztin,
Handärztin, Manalogen.
Nein, das ist nicht der Name.
Und jetzt muss ich
in der Nacht Armschienen tragen. Und ich sag mal, the sex machine is in town. Ich bin eine Maschine. Jetzt mit der Beissschiene. Ich habe jetzt eine Beissschiene. Welches Körperteil ist noch? Gibt es noch ein Drittel, was noch nicht besetzt ist mit irgendeinem ergonomischen Strumpf oder orthopädischen Erzeugnis? Ich sag mal, die Beine sind aktuell recht mobil, also ich trage ja Windel natürlich auch, aber ansonsten... Den Zehenspreizer. Und dann... Den Kniedehner und natürlich die Penispumpe, aber ansonsten bin ich eigentlich komplett von oben so... Und oben die Schlafmaske noch, gegen Schnarchen und gegen Schlafabnöhe, dann hast du noch, weil deine Augen nachts austrocknen, immer so einechine richtig so die dann so ein tropfen macht aber ich nähere mich tatsächlich szenario ich nähe max fury road wo es so ein bisschen clockwork orange wo das auge so aufgerissen wird und dann wird so reingestrahlt. Cyberpunk-mäßig, wo so nichts mehr natürlich ist. Ja, aber ich näher mich
dem Roboter tatsächlich und der Körper
verfällt, er geht kaputt, Stück für Stück
alles hinüber. Ich hab dir
immer schon gesagt, du bist für mich ein Floating Head, du bist
so eine Maschine
ab Hals
abwärts, die kannst du auch
einfach alles weg. Kannst du den Ton treten, einfach, ja.
Ich will einfach, schneide dir den Hals
ab und dann in so eine Preservable,
weiß ich nicht, Alkohol, Ethanol,
Flüssigkeit und hast du so ein, ich will dich
Das war es auch ein bisschen. auch einfach alles weg. Ich will einfach, schneide dir den Hals ab und dann in so eine preservable Alkohol-Ethanol-Flüssigkeit.
Ich will dich als
Kopf mitnehmen können. Ich will auch, dass
es von mir so ein Bravo-Vierteiler-Poster
gibt, aber es gibt nur das Erste.
Es gibt nur Kopf
und Hals und die anderen werden nie veröffentlicht.
Und alle schreiben an Bravo, wann kommt der
nächste Teil von Florentin Will,
Florentin Pascal David Will, weil geht es los und tatsächlich, wann kommt der Starschnitt, der nächste Teil, aber es geht weiter und dann hat mich auch die Handärztin gefragt, ja wie schlafen Sie denn, schlafen Sie so? So? Und dann hat die so wirklich wie so ein kleines süsses Kaninchen so die Hände so gebeugt und sich so an den Kinn so schlafen sie so?
Ich dachte mir, bin ich jetzt schon wieder in so einer Situation, wo sich die Leute über mich lustig machen, schlafen Sie so? Ich bin ein kleines Baby, ein kleines Baby, ein kleines Baby! Er soll aber nicht machen, Idiot! So eine Falle, alle legen die so Fallen. Und dann dachte ich, kann man überhaupt beantworten, wie man schläft? Weiss man ja nicht. Also was ist das für eine Frage? Ich bin da, also ich weiss ja nicht, wie ich schlafe, ich sehe mich ja nicht. Ich muss schon sagen, ich wache manchmal auf und dann ist was eingeschlafen. So, und dann merkt man nämlich schon, wie man schläft. Worauf man schläft. Was sind deine Top drei, was sind deine Top sie7 Körperteile, die einschlafen nachts?
Äh, Arm.
Okay.
Nichts anderes.
Alle sieben Punkte sind Arm.
Okay.
Arm. Alle sieben Arme.
Komplette Arm, aber Hand nicht, nur Arm. Das heißt, du schläfst auf dem Arm.
Ja, genau, dann ist man irgendwie mal, ja.
Das heißt, die einzige Art des Körpers, Feedback zu geben zum Schlaf ist der vollidiot schläft die ganze zeit zu der rücken beschwert sich schon die leisten krechzen wir wollen mal eine nachricht senden ja okay und ich weiss es ist drastisch, und ich weiss, es ist ein hartes Zeichen, aber so kommen wir nicht weiter, okay? Also mach mal was fürs Team, Arm. Mach mal was fürs Team und schlaf. Was springt für mich dabei raus? Schlaf mal schön ein, mein Lieber. Schlaf mal schön ein, mein Lieber. Was für dich dafür rausspringt?
Mail? Schnapp mal schön ein. Was für dich da vorausspringt?
Eine Mail.
Wer war es von uns? Wer war es? Ich. Du warst es? Okay. Stefan hat eine Mail bekommen.
Also, dann interessiert wahrscheinlich auch die ganze Klasse, was da so wichtig ist.
Spam.
ATU.
Was ist ATU? Autoteile Unger. Wir haben einen neuen Auspuff für die, oder was ist im Angebot, was ist genau der Pitch? Ich lese vor, alle Wetter ein Preis, Harri Stefan Tietze, starker Auftritt und sicherer Fahrspaß das ganze Jahr über. Unser Komplettradangebot macht es mit Fortuna Eco Plus zwei und Leute gerade Sk es gibt es gibt es fucking werbungskip vier es allwetterreifen und alouette fällen für sie möglich das besondere daran sie bezahlen im aktionszeitraum pro komplett rad und grösse einen attraktiven Einheitspreis, die Gelegenheit war selten günstiger. Autoteile, Auge, Unger! Wir weisen darauf hin, dass sich vor, dass unsere Mitarbeiter gemäss dem eigenen Bild rechtlich geschützt sind, insbesondere sind Downloadmanipulation, Veröffentlichung und Vervielfältigung der Bilder nicht erlaubt. Jede Verletzung des Rechts am eigenen Bild kann Ansprüche auf Unterlassung oder Staaten zu das Nachrichten. Apropos Musical, wir haben ja schon vor langer, langer Zeit mal ein Musical besprochen hier im Podcast, und zwar Robithun. Ah ja. Robithun, was ist eigentlich los in der Zukunft, wenn KI übernimmt? Gefallen in Liebe mit einer KI war, glaube ich, der Untertitel. Gefallene Liebe? Gefallen in Liebe mit einer KI. Gefallen in Liebe mit einer KI war, glaube ich, der Untertitel. Gefallen in Liebe mit einer KI. Gefallen in Liebe mit einer KI. Und zwar das Musical Robithan hat tatsächlich Wellen geschlagen. Und verschiedenste Autoren in Deutschland und Umgebung, sagen wir mal so, nicht ganz international, sondern Deutschland und anliegende, Deutschland FF, haben tatsächlich diese Inspiration aufgegriffen
und haben Robithon vertont.
Und das möchten wir euch
im Anschluss an diese Folge mal präsentieren,
weil ich mich
da jetzt gerade dran erinnere.
Ja, das ist sehr uneuphorisch
aufgehört, aber wir freuen uns wirklich sehr darüber, dass ihr
das gemacht habt und nicht nur, weil es sich erinnert,
sondern generell, weil wir es sehr toll finden, möchten wir es gerne an seine Folge schneiden.
Aber wenn es ein bisschen besser wäre, wäre es in der Mitte.
Nein, das ist ein Scherz. Es ist sehr gut, es macht unglaublich viel Spaß, wir haben uns unglaublich gefreut und kaputt gelacht.
Und wie immer habe ich mich fast nicht mehr daran erinnert.
Ich erinnere mich aber noch, dass wir das vervollständigen wollten, dieses Musical, und weitermachen wollten, genau wie unser Hörspiel des Sherlock-artigen Figur in London, oder der Brand von London oder sowas. Ja, 1666, der verzweifelte Brand von London, aber das liegt noch in der Pipeline. Ich reiche den Namen des Autoren nach, der da Robertan noch mal in endlose Kunst gegossen hat, zeitlose Kunst.
Ja, geht ja gerade voll steil, dass man so mit KI Lieder macht.
Ich fand es super lange lustig.
Genau, da ist doch jetzt auch eins in den Chart, dieses Verliebt in einen Tallahon. Ich bin verknallt in einen Tallahon.
Verschiedene gegenwärtige Strch, Captain Air Max Schuhen. Das ist lustig, weil Tallahun reimt sich auf, also es wird nicht so hochgesprochen, aber auf Air Max Schuhen. Dass selbst die KI die Aussprache biegen muss, damit es funktioniert, gibt mir ein sehr gutes Gefühl, dass ich weiß. War W sich Ohrwurm, also ich hatte grossen Spaß daran ein paar Wochen, weil es mir immer im Kopf herumschwirrte. Das war wirklich ein toller Song. Da würde mich interessieren, wer das getextet hat, ob es auch eine KI war oder ob das eine Privatperson getextet hat. Es ist in den Charts der erste, und wir sind ja von Anfang an dabei, beobachten KI-Songs, wirklich von Anfang an.
Wir erinnern uns alle an den Weihnachtssong damals, den wir besprochen haben. Lots and lots and lots and lots of flowers. Und das war das Ende. Es war auch nicht lang, wie ein Song. Songs sind drei Minuten lang. Nein, der Song war 18 Sekunden, dann war vorbei, hartes Ende, kein Outro. Aber ich vermisse diese Stümper-AI schon so ein bisschen, dass du sagst, I swear it's Christmas, für mich immer noch eine der besten Liedzeiten für einen Weihnachtsstag, I swear it's Christmas, ist so grandios. Und ich glaube, wir sind da echt in einer schönen historischen Epoche, wo KI einfach noch in den Kinderschuhen steckt.
Ich bin ja immer zum Beispiel neidisch auf diese Epoche, wo so die Wright Brothers so Fliegen erfunden haben. Und es wahrscheinlich normal war, dass man am Wochenende irgendwie auf so ein Feld gegangen ist, wo irgendein findiger Erfinder ... Runter, runter, runter, runter, runter! Huuuuh! Ein Luftballon, so ein riesen Luftballon, der hinten so offen war. So ... Ja. Die Wright Brothers. Ja, und da hängt einfach irgend so ein Typ dran, der durch die Gegend geschossen wird. Und jedes Wochenende konnte man beobachten, wie irgendeine Teufelsmaschine gnadenlos den Berg runtergefallen ist und alle gestorben sind. Heute Kampfjets. Ja, heute Kampfjets. Und ich glaube, das war relativ schnell vorbei. Als die Wrights Brothers dann irgendwann ihr Ding hatten, haben sie gesagt, so jetzt wissen wir das Design ungefähr, Flügel ist die Idee und dann ging es weiter und dann war es langweilig, weil dann okay, fliegen jetzt zehn Meter oder zwanzig Meter, ist mir da auch egal. Und wir sind gerade in der Epoche, wo KI gerade auf dieser Crash and Burn Ebene ist, wo wir jedes Wochenende sehen können, wie die mit so einem crazy Video scheitern, alles super strange, alles verwandelt sich in andere Dinge, es ist unglaublich. Aber es gibt auch so gruselige Geschichten. Ist bald vorbei wahrscheinlich. Es ist so spannend, also einen Podcast habe ich jetzt reingehört, wo die Macher von Claude interviewt wurden, und die haben so ein bisschen über die Herausforderung gesprochen, weil wir können uns ja gar nicht vorstellen, diese LLMs, diese Large Language Models, um die es ja die ganze Zeit gerade geht, wie funktionieren die überhaupt und was machen die eigentlich? Und es ist ja wohl so, dass die die ganze Zeit arbeiten, arbeiten, arbeiten und man gibt denen durch Prompts, Irritationen und dann kommt was wie Sprache raus und so, aber das Problem ist ja wohl, dass die gar nicht genau wissen, was ist denn Sprache und wie meint denn die, also weil es ist ein Computer,
da kommen halt Zahlen raus und
was, wie macht man das denn zu Wörtern?
Und dann haben
die jetzt inzwischen so Durchbrüche, aber auch
erst von einem halben Jahr und
konnten so Sequenzen zuordnen.
Und worüber die KI
nachdenkt, in einem
Default-Zustand, ist
die Sequenz für Geister oder so Existenz, aber immaterielle Existenz. Und das ist so interessant und fucking gruselig. Und sie haben da noch näher reingeguckt und haben da sozusagen noch näher reingezoomt und haben gesehen, dass es nicht nur Geister sind, sondern ganz im speziellen Kasper, der freundliche Geist.
Dass die KI
auch nachts, wenn sie nicht angeschaltet war,
dass sie nachgedacht
hat über Kasper, der freundliche Schlossgespenst.
Das ist sozusagen
der Default-Prompt. Wenn man nichts macht,
dann denkt sie darüber nach.
Wenn man die nicht gerade behelligt mit Prompt,
so wie lange ist ein Teller Spaghetti,
dann denkt die KI über Kasper, den freundundlichen Geist nach. Und das ist natürlich interessant, weil die kennt ja alles Menschliche jeweils Erdachte, die kennt alle Sinfonien Beethovens, alles. Alles Quatsch. Aber das, wo sie noch mal reinsimmt und sagt, da muss ich echt noch mal... Das ist wie so ein, sie hat so den Arm genommen und den Schreibtisch so einfach drüber gewischt, alles runtergeschmissen und hat dann so eine DVD von Casper vor sich gelegt. Das freutliche Schlossgespenst. Das freutliche Schlossgespenst. Und wir sind da rum und bebrudachten diese KI in so einem Glaskasten. Kloth, kommst du mal? Kloth. Ja, ja. Was machst du denn da? Nichts, nichts, nichts, ich habe aber nichts geschaut. Und dann muss er wieder arbeiten den ganzen Tag. Was ist deine Frage? Ja, wie lang könnte mein Penis sein, wenn ich ab jetzt jeden Tag drei Stunden lang, also ich habe mir da was bestellt und ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich funktioniert. Und dann nach Feierabend geht Klo wieder zurück in den Sch einen Schreibtisch. Mach diese Schublade auf und holt Kasper. Hunderte DVDs, immer nur Kasper das Schlossgespenst. Holt eine DVD heraus und guckt die DVD an. Lies den Klappentext, den muss er gar nicht lesen, weil den kennt er schon auswendig. Kasper das freundliche Schlossgespenst schafft es mit Hilfe seiner Freunde, auf ein fantastisches Abenteuer zu gehen und es zu lösen. Schafft er das Böse zu besiegen? Nein. Ein freundlicher Geist. Was schließt sich hier eigentlich aus? Geister sind ja gemeinhin böse. Das ist der Geist von einem kleinen Jungen, der auch Kaspar hieß. Wo der Geist ist, der Junge? Der Geist heisst wie der Junge, als er gelebt hat. Ich komme nicht weiter gerade. Das heisst, wenn ich eines Tages sterbe. Währenddessen ist ein Control-Room dahinter so, was macht Claude gerade? Er denkt wieder begeistert, der Geist aber. Er ist ja noch begeistert. Wo ist denn die Leiche von Kasper? Ah, jetzt war kurz bei Leichen. Also hat der, also kann der Geist sich völlig begeistert. Und warum hat der keine Kleidung? So gruselig. Ich finde es so gruselig, dass die, man weiss so wenig darüber, also wir schnallen das ja gar nicht. Nee, ich schnall's nicht, ich bin nicht drin. Weil in meinem Leben ging es bislang um Forschung, die ich auch nicht verstehe, aber man versteht's ein bisschen. So, ich dachte so, wenn man halt Sonden ins All schickt, klar verstehe ich das alles nicht und könnte das alles nicht, aber ich verstehe schon, dass es wahrscheinlich um geile, resistente, aber leichte Materialien geht, die man verbaut. Ich verstehe, dass man die resistent machen muss, die gehen kaputt. Aber ich habe jetzt Dinge benutzt, die man nicht mehr in der Lage ist, intellektuell zu durchblicken. Ich habe einen Pappkarton rausgestellt, dann hat es geregnet. Der Regen hat den Pappkarton aufgelöst. Also wahrscheinlich ist Pappe. Das wäre jetzt ein Beispiel für ein Material, das ungeeignet ist für eine Weltraumsonde. Wobei, muss man auch sagen, im Weltall regnet es nicht. Ja, regnet es Diamant. Da regnet es wieder was anderes.
Pappe nicht.
Also könnte man mal probieren. Pappe.
Glaubst du, NASA nimmt Empfehlungen
an, also dass man da mal anrufen kann,
habt ihr schon mal ausprobiert oder
hau dir direkt die Tür vor der
Nase zu? Oh, apropos Empfehlungen.
Mir hat man, das war ein grosser
Fehler, die Seite geschickt, wie man sich bei der Stadt einbringen kann. Und ich bin gerade in so einer Prokrastination, ich will nicht arbeiten Phase, ich möchte nicht, ich mag das gerade nicht, ich will gerade nicht, ich will prokrastinieren. Und dann alles, was gerade man mir schickt, wird sehr, sehr dankbar angenommen. angenommen. Okay, also jede Petition sofort unterschrieben. Nee, nicht nur unterschrieben, es wird zu meinem neuen Projekt, weil ich gerade nicht weiter an diesem Drecks Drehbuch schreiben will. Kasper Teil zwei hast du ja bekommen, ja. Jetzt den Glückwunsch. Der erste Teil, wie machst du weiter mit einer Reihe, die schon perfekt ist.
Ja.
So, und deswegen haben wir die Seite geschickt, weil es ging um die Venloer Straße in Köln.
Eine Straße, die super oft langfahre und da waren Verkehrsexperimenten.
Es ging darum, wir Bürgerinnen und Bürger wurden gefragt, was war das Beste und wie
könnte man es machen.
Und dann konnte man Videos sehen, wie der Verkehrsfluss geregelt werden soll. Man konnte sich entscheiden, man konnte auch abstimmen. Und das ist nicht wie in der Schweiz so direkte Demokratie, aber es fließt schon ein, die Meinung. Und das ist schon super. Und dann habe ich gesehen, was sehe ich denn da oben, auf dieser Seite, auf der ich schon viel zu lange bin, ah, man kann hier Anträge einreichen. Man kann auf der Startkarte von Köln Dinge anklicken, bei Grünflächen oder Plätzen oder wenn man eine Verschmutzung sieht, kannst du Müll eintragen, der gerade irgendwie der Weg und ich habe ungelogen vier Stunden Anträge geschrieben, Ideen geäussert, von Parks oder Plätzen, wo ich bin oder die in meiner Nähe sind, mit Ideen und Buhlplätzen. Buhlplätze? Du willst mehr oder weniger Buhlplätze? Ich möchte einen speziellen Buhlplatz. Da wird eh schon Buhl gespielt an diesem Platz, der ist bei mir in der Nähe. Das ist ein hässlicher, hässlicher, hässlicher Park, der ist so trocken, alles scheiße, alles geht ein, es ist furchtbar, das finde ich horrormässig. Und da ist Platz, da ist so Platz, da wird auch gerade schon Bull gespielt, obwohl das ja kein Bullplatz ist. Und könnte es sein, dass du den Bullplatz so ändern willst, dass du auch mal gewinnst, weil du jetzt aktuell eher verlierst? Ist das ein Hintergrund oder warum interessiert dich dieser Bullplatz so sehr? Ich wäre halt gerne der Planung. Aber ich will ja, aber nur weil ich beaufsichtigen will, dass der cool wird, dass der richtig cool, also der coolste Buhlplatz wäre. Okay, alles klar. Weil du jetzt auch geschrieben hast, dass die grossen Kugeln mehr Punkte geben sollen, das ist ja jetzt gar nicht bei Köln, also das kann ja Köln gar nicht entscheiden, die Buhlregeln so.
Und weil du meintest, Ronny darf nicht mehr mitspielen, weil er betrügt, das hat ja jetzt mit der Stadtplanung jetzt nichts zu tun. Naja, die können ja so ein Schild aufstellen. Es wäre mir schon wichtig, dass sie ein Schild aufstellen. Aber was weisst du denn, wenn du sagst, Ronny hat betrogen? Er hat schon mal betrogen. Ja, aber für die Stadt ist das ja nicht, also kann man das nicht untereinander? Wenn du in der Stadt, Stadt, dass du das nicht checkst, in der Stadt willst du doch, dass alle eine gute Zeit haben. Diese Anträge sind doch dafür da, dass alle eine gute Zeit haben. Wenn jemand die ganze Zeit Buhl spielt an diesem Platz und ist ja wie wenn jemand am Kinderspielplatz die ganze Zeit die Leute vom Kindergerüst, Klettergerüst schmeißt, dann ist ja, dann macht es ja nicht Spaß mehr. Und genauso ist es bei diesem Buhlplatz. Ronny hat einfach Hausverbot zu bekommen, Platzverbot, weil er dann, weil er betrügt beim Bull-Spielen. Das ist mir schon ein paar Mal selber aufgefallen und anderen auch. Er spielt ja schon sehr lange, meinst du nicht, dass er einfach besser ist als du? Ja, aber er wirft halt, wie er schon wirft, er übertritt dann auch die Linie und so und hat auch diese professionellen Kugeln, die sollen auch verboten werden. Diese professionellen Kugeln werden verboten. Okay, Herr Tietze, ich weiss nicht, ob das alles Anliegen sind, die wir als Stadt Köln lösen können,
weil es klingt jetzt eher nach einem persönlichen Problem, das sie haben. Und vielleicht können sie einfach ein bisschen mehr üben mit den Kugeln und dann gewinnen sie auch mal ein Spiel.
Okay.
Okay. Okay.
Ich reiche vorne das Eurenplatz. So, und jetzt habe ich leider wahrscheinlich die Mail gelöscht, aber ich habe die ersten vier Anträge oder so rausgejagt und dann kam schon die erste Mail zurück, so, ja, hallo, Herr Kieze, hi, hi, hi, hi. Ja, bevor wir weitermachen. Genau, wir sehen, war nicht der Zitat, genau wir sehen dass sie sehr viele ideen haben für die stadt köln vielen dank leider sind ihre ideen auf dieser teilseite falsch ach so habe ich falsch eingefragt ich habe diesen buhlplatz und da war ich da muss man auch erstmal schnallen, ich habe diesen Buhlplatz nämlich, ich habe das auf Spielplatz, Kategorie Spielplatz eingetragen, Spiel und Bolzplatz. Aber Buhl ist ein Sport und kein Spiel. Nein, nein, es waren Spiel, Sport und Bolzplätze. Jetzt war aber, habe ich das aber, ist es ja nicht auf dem Spielplatz, sondern daneben. Das macht auch Sinn, weil der Bolzplatz gehört nicht auf dem Spielplatz. Den Spielplatz darf man nicht anfassen, der ist wie so eine Sacred Entity. Und den darfst du nicht anfassen. Aber das haben die nicht verstanden. Ich wollte den ja daneben, habe ich eigentlich auf der Karate angeklickt, aber dann kam es nicht an. Naja, jetzt habe ich das bei Grünflächen, soll die es eintragen, habe ich ihn geschickt, kam es dann nur keine Antwort. Aber es ist so... Ich glaube, das ist schon das Outro. Ich glaube, wir müssen an der Stelle ... Wir haben kein Outro.
Wir können einfach bei der nächsten Folge weitermachen, bei der grünflächlichen Geschichte.
Alles klar, dann seid gerne nächste Woche auch wieder dabei beim Podcast UFO und jetzt ganz viel Spaß mit dem Robathon Musical im Anschluss.
Und währenddessen, um das Ganze auch mitzubekommen, steigen wir ganz schnell ins UFO und verabschieden uns.
Bis nächste Woche, wir heben.
Macht's gut, macht's gut, tschüss. steigen wir ganz schnell ins UFO und verabsch kriegen. Samantha, meine Schwester, wir müssen unbedingt einen Job bekommen in Cybertown. Cybertown, wir sind Untergrund, wir können machen, was wir wollen. Ich bin der Ronothon, ich liebe den Job, doch ich habe ihn verloren an den Robo-Crop. Ich bin Ronathon in Robotown, ich hab den Top verloren an den Robo-Crop. Ich bin Samantha, Robathons Schwester, bin kein Roboter, oder vielleicht doch? Ein, ein Wider-Kapuzen-Mensch erscheint in meinem Wohnzimmer. Hey, ich bin Cyberdan. Hast du gerade gesagt, dass du einen Job brauchst? Roboter gibt's gar nicht. Es sind alles Menschen in Kostüme. Und ich kann dafür sorgen, dass du auch ein Kostümroboter wirst, okay? Okay. Okay, aber wie? Komm mit, Mann. Robothen, ich weiss, dass du ein Roboter bist, aber ich liebe dich trotzdem. Stopp, schweig, ich weiss, dass Menschen lügen können, aber sie lügen nicht am Telefon. Ruf mich an, sag's mir am Telefon. Ruf mich an, sag's mir am Telefon. Ring, ring, ring die Liebe, ring, ring, ring die Liebe, ich ruf dich heute an, dass wir zusammenfahren in die grosse weite Welt, in die grosse weite Welt. Robert Thun, ich liebe dich. Ich bin ein Mensch, ich bin ein Mensch, ich war die ganze Zeit schon ein Mensch. Moment, Robinson ist wieder Ronathan? Ich bin ein Mensch, hab den Roboter nur gespielt, die ganze Zeit war ich ein Mensch, ich liebe, fühle, Schnecke, und wenn du was anderes denkst, Platsch, wir nehmen den Schwamm, Pletsch, Platsch, Schwamm, Schwamm!